hi my name is Leslie Bowl thank you so
much for being here thank you my
question is our last guest here Bruce
Cohen mentioned when speaking about
LGBTQ rights that the fight is never
over and used the civil rights movement
as an example and I just curious to hear
your thoughts on the statement that the
fight is never over and what you think
then main area in civil rights we should
be fighting for today is I hope he
wasn't saying the fight will never be
over because i believe the fight one day
will be over the fight for black rights
is not over the fact of LBT rights is
not over these fights are ongoing and
while progress has been made in each of
these two disparate fields of endeavor
gains have been made victories have been
won this is not the same country today
for anybody in either of these groups
today as it was say 20 30 40 years ago
so changes has been made and changes
being made almost daily but the day is
going to come I believe that we will say
wow we've put all that behind us and
we've made so many victories that
there's very little to worry about now
the ongoing battles in the struck the
search for civil rights I think one
thing that we've not paid them as much
attention to as we ought to and this is
just one of many is the problem of
segregated housing if you look around
the United States it's still a matter of
fact despite a recent report by a
right-wing group in New York City that's
racial segregation and housing and
almost disappeared first of all it's not
true secondly it's pervasive and thirdly
it just harms people of color so
dangerously and I'm just amazed that
we've not done more about it if you live
in a segregated system of the city yours
and you're black you're separated from
the best schools the best houses the
best opportunities and the chances
you're achieving those things are
diminished because of where you live so
to the degree that we're able to stop
this physical segregation of people
that's the degree to which they're able
to have access to these opportunities
and their condition improves that's
something we need to work on